今天的第二个环节我估计也是很多同学非常感兴趣的因为包括今天我们也有很多同学在直播间问这个问题就是关于戴老师的一个鞋杠人生因为戴老师确实是一方面技术特别特别的在我们圈子里面也算是真的我们都叫他老师嘛那肯定是大师级别的人物了然后另外其实他在画领域也有非常自己多的一些一些建筑所以我们今天可能会围绕他的一个鞋杠人生来展开今天的一个对话部分
对在开始之前的话我们有一个问题直播间其实有两个问题我们还是可以问一下第一个就是有一个同学问到关于说iOS这边后续要学习的话是学oc还是学swift就戴老师你这边是怎么看的这个问题学swift我觉得这个其实我今年这个WSA里面就是那个哥们那哥们其实很早我就看过他的这个大学里面那个课程公开课的
然后当时我进不上看听完了以后依据都没听完刚开始学的时候但那根本还是很牛的然后他当时就在那个那个达伯丁声里面他不是后面有一个写着现在开发这个iOS开发APP就要用swift对他都这么说了就没有不用想其他的对对
OK 然後還有一個問題就是關於因為其實我們今天講這個LLVM的話涉及到大量的比如說我們需要原碼去編譯那個開源版本的LLVM包括一些別的庫嘛那有同學會問就是如果用開源版本編譯的這個APP的話去上架審核是能通過的嗎呃剛才不小心走聲不好意思是是那個就是就是如果我們用開源的LLVM去編譯就是自己編譯的那個APP是可以上傳Apple它審核
是会通过的吗这个问题对这个可以试一下但是也也不一定非得就是用他编的东西去上传啊就说嗯呃呃谁要可以用他做一些就是说分析啊或者先下来一些事情然后到了你真的要上传的时候其实你也可以把一些就是他做的这些事情然后放在你的构建流程里面去通过其他的方式也能也能做到做到这一步嗯ok明白好的
好的这两个问题其实应该还是比较惊艳因为直播间包括第二个问题有很多同学在问那我觉得可能就是答案就是你开发的过程中其实可以可以来做就线下来用嘛但是线上的话还是用这种官方标准的就是插过来打包去构建踢脚就可以了对吧好的那我们现在就继续走入金融中间的访谈部分吧首先肯定是第一个问题是想了解一下就是戴老师目前在就是快手嘛
你是参加一个什么样的角色呢然后主要做一些什么样的事情从这个工作的这个方向上来说的话我主要还是会做一些就是长期收益的技术方向的一些圣灯门然后还有这个做一些开源的事情然后具体到这个因为我大块手是有一年嗯一年多很多了一年半应该是有了然后我应该做了做了三大块事吧就第一个是这个
iPad这样一个适配第二个就是把sweep引到快手工程里面去另外一个就是说在编译相关这一块看是会做一些偏长期的收益的一些调研对iPad的适配来说的话其实还是看起来没有什么但对我来说是一个很大的挑战为什么呢因为刚到快手的时候一个人不熟然后工程也不熟
然后当时做这一块的时候是带着六个同样也不熟悉的就是笑着声然后一起来做这个事情我觉得真的挺有眼神然后当时从这个地方来说的话呢就说因为他适配确实嗯从官方提供的这些回调上面来说倒还好但是呢因为工程时间比较长了以后呢像一些福利安穆啊这种写法适配起来会非常的困难调试啊
等等等然后还有UiWindows这个地方就是有很多的问题就是特别不好做但是用自动布局写的话会稍微好一点点所以后面如果就是当这个Swift或者SwiftUI这种声明式的这种编写界面的方法就弄好了以后然后这种设备就是很容易了就会很容易因为它都是这种小认识的对吧比较好做一些
另外还有Swift的这一块也是,首先我觉得它主要是在收益这一块,就是说Swift到底解决的是什么样的问题,首先我觉得它这一块因为Oc来说它实际上跟Swift的比,它的安全性会差很多,因为它是在运行过程中才会发现问题的,但是Swift实际上它实际上是
很好的解决这个就比如说OC它是基于这个C的语言它有这个指针然后它也有不完全的这种触碰触碰画的这个变量然后也会输足越接压这些等等这些问题然后这话其实你能够像这个这个这个他们苹果对这个工具链还有这个工具链就Scode还有这个编辑LVM他们有完全的控制权的话也没法很好的解决这个问题解决像DugglingPoint
这种生命中心的问题啊就是C只要是C的远它就没有一个框架是能够解决这个然后改成这个监动的方式进行系统它也是行不通的谁说这个苹果他们团队呢谁才决定创造一个新的远因为这种问题没有没解的时候肯定还是得用更更先进的东西去替代它然后呢更安全这是一个一个是安全而另外一个就是嗯就说呃他的这个
写法吧比较简单这个其实没有什么太多好说的然后好处我觉得这也不是一下子能说的完的所以就只能说太多太多了这就是另外一个比较大的主题然后长期收益了这一块就说我觉得是也是今后的一个方向吧因为这一块能够取得一些突破的话我觉得也能够把整个这个团队往前推一步
我也这个是一个比较有意思的事情然后总的来说角色那就是一个要做一个好的技术专家嗯明白对因为我我根据戴老师的描述来看确实现在还是一个就是就是其实一个专家方向吧因为我觉得戴老师确实会讲到嗯他不仅会讲到一些很多方向性的东西而且其实他在讲一些细节的时候也是就就是又有一个全局的把控然后对于细节的把控也是非常非常到位的ok
然后呢其实就引出第二个问题啊因为其实我理解大老师他你也是从一个新手拍发者一步步成长到现在这样的一个阶段的嘛那你再就是你你回顾一下就是你在这样的一个过程中你今天的哪些阶段呢对实际上我今天也听说有很多高校同学过来听然后我我觉得我当年读书的那一会其实就是因为比较单纯就是也没有什么
其他的想法就是觉得什么那我有类型我就愿意干啥就是比如说那个时候学生都穷然后钱就是所以我赚钱就是最有类型的事情然后我就会就是因为赚钱得干活嘛所以就会去接很多的项目就做一些项目然后会用到 ASP 的这种语言因为那个时候很早的时候还是 ASP 比较流行那个时候
当然我刚开始做这个项目的时候我连 cookie 啊session 都复不清楚然后还get a post 都更不用说了然后当然我刚才说这两个点啊一般跟辩子提会问然后我接活的时候是不会有人问的所以说那别人只看你的学校啊然后他只会说哎那你们能干呢那小孩子嘛胆子比较大然后什么技术都感觉然后反正接了再学呗当时看书我也不看你们只看例子
然後對著虛擾感,對著虛擾雜力,就這樣。然後也做了Flash,Flash當時也變得流行。然後他使用的腳步語言是ActionScript,也是跟GS一樣,遵循ECM Action第四版當時是。那個時候還做了一個,就說大學的時候還做了一個在清華東森那邊,當時用Defy寫這個數據庫,老闆是台灣人。
然后我印象最深就是学校里面吃的不行在那儿自助餐特别丰盛而且还很好吃然后呢其实我大学做的这些技术其实对后来的影响都比较的深比如像ASP它实际上是服务端的然后我后来就用了用了用过PHP然后像Flash呢我后来也用了这个Java Scrape但反而它客户端嘛后来就是现在一直在做的这个客户端的这个事情所以我觉得
大学还很重要就是这样子然后另外那个时候就说其实我觉得当时也是只能做事这样子然后后来到了创业公司以后然后其实也可以理解我走了很多弯弯然后当时在创业公司的时候我是什么都做然后也做管理然后做产品也做设计当然开发也会做然后用户的量级不大然后也没有没有机会去学深入学习这些技术
因為沒有這個數角然後服單你如果用戶不多你基本上是不會去研究這些技術的然後接下來創意過程完了以後去的事業單位其實也屬於一個玩弄當時是用這個開發後端然後前端也開始要自己做那個時候其實還好就是不會讓你去做很多的事情但是我自己比較喜歡去做這樣一些技術然後那個時候比較頭疼的就是
学前端的时候要坚弄这个i6然后i6就基本上所有当时前端的户全都是坚弄i6的这些不像现在还有很多很高级的这些这些思想在里面那以后去研究一些开发校园那个时候很多大部分都是当干基本上就不会考虑这个这个架构的问题主要是为了坚弄然后比较然后我实际上在这个期间的也做到自己的这个网站
而且后端都是自己实现的然后再到后面就是互联网公司的经历就基本上如果了解我能经常都是从我去到互联网公司第一家是这个滴滴然后开始就是就知道我的然后我觉得那个时候才是真的技术才开始在进入因为首先用户比较多了然后你碰到的这些问题
就是很恐怖你要自己做东西没能给你反馈你要是到了这种全国里面都在用的这种APP你基本上是不可能解完那种的解完这些这些这些办法杆或者这些问题的所以那个时候就要求就会比较高我觉得那个时候技术进步的是比较快的因为挑战比较大嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯
确实很丰富的工作金你包括创业啊然后甚至在在这种事业单位还待过没有意思包括你刚才讲的你大家时候学的那些语言感觉确实是上古时期才会对吧也上古时期的语言那那你觉得从我的业就比如其实你觉得真正的纪录的成长其实是在你进入不了网公司这些之后然后有一些比较大的成长对不对对没错
那那是不是也可以说是大气完成确实还没成 还没成所以已经已经很厉害了我说实话就从从我们这些普通开发者而言的话戴老师其实已经站在了一个至少在iOS圈里面也是在一个top的一个状态了那其实我觉得可以给大家一些思考就是怎么说呢就是第一个也其实也不怕晚就很多同学可能对吧戴老师我估计年龄不方便透但是肯定也是有有挺多年工作经验的就是说
就其实你的成长其实是不怕晚的只要你能保持一个这种对这个东西一个学习的热忱然后对于高校同学就更加说了就就更更那个什么因为对于你们来说你们还非常非常年轻对吧其实可能就如果以大老师为例的话你们已经领先很多了是不是可以这么理解你是太多你是太多对ok好的ok那那其实就想问一下就比如说在这个过程中吧就你觉得对你成长帮助最大的三个点是什么呢嗯
对这三个点就是第一个我觉得点就是主要是我个人的这个经历造成的就是说第一个我觉得对成长最大的帮助的是多走弯路然后第二个是这个就一个问题他解决的方案啊就是不停的叠态更新然后去托付他然后第三个就是要记录和分享就像今天我在这分享一下那我先记录下来然后再分享给大家然后对于走这个弯路这一块就是这这一点
来说的话呢就是呃就说不光是这个工作这个时长的这个网络就是还有就是说比如说做一个以前这个嗯就刚开始学二还是时候我就会做APP嘛那APP会有比较复杂的这个历史的列表然后我刚开始学的时候呢就说也没有太多的去了解它因为比较好的方式大家可能想到了就是说我可能想要找一个类似的开源项码或者问一些高手是吧
但是我上手的时候就没有我上手的时候就经常就直接上手所以开始上手的时候发现问题特别多比如说塞尔的这个种类就很多然后他根据种类类就会展示很多不同的类型然后我我我根据呢就是就是这个数据来设置这个他每个塞尔他有的椅子黑能然后来发现这个塞尔里面的这个内容滚起来的时候他会串就直接你设这个椅子黑能会串而当真的是百事不得其我怎么试他都会有问题然后后来呢
到最后我就已经试了无数遍了然后周末都在意识设然后最后在初识化的这个地方然后先设置一次然后再去设置这个这个这个意识配的就两个不同的回料世界里面设置都设置进去然后才才会好然后呢当我碰了这么多的困难而且也想了很多然后这个时候我就很有动力去了解它这个原理是什么的所以我就觉得多走点弯路实际上可以看到更多的东西然后就说呃虽然
大气晚神就是可能听起来不是那么好听啊但是我觉得当然不是说我啊我我还没成啊就是我觉得大气晚神就是也代表着就是你看到了很多就是大气早晨的可能没看到那些风景然后也很舒服所以我觉得走弯路这是我觉得比较有帮助的第二个点就是一个方法上多段的图我觉得呃光走弯路肯定也是不行的就说呃
真正能够带来这个突破我感觉还是从这个方案上要不断的去做就比如像这个刚才我也介绍了这个包体积这个问题想像做的这个次数也特别的多然后每次做完了其实也也会有很多的收益然后就比如第一次我做这个收益的时候当时就还挺大然后后来这个方法呢就遇到了第二家公司呢然后发现
就是可能别人都已经做了因为也分享然后反正大家也互相会学习嘛然后已经没有什么做了然后还想再压然后所以就再去功课就像前面提到是从产物找少然后再从这个克兰这个技术找少然后后面还有什么连接时候这个压缩案然后会了解一些连接器的知识就是说不断的在一个问题上去找更多的方案的时候呢你了解知识感我感觉了解知识会更多一些然后最后刚刚提到这个Pass叉状
可能以前就对这个编辑前端可能输一点然后到后来呢就对这个中间这一端怕是这一块就是会有更多的兴德跟实践然后这样来说同样一个问题然后反反复复去想去图也是一个很好的方法嗯然后同时呢就是因为你想图的话嘛就一定会去看很多资料就大量的数据啊然后去图书馆去查呀然后
把有用的记录下然后到记录和分享分享的时候就会发现你像今天我的这个主题实际上是讲了几次了然后每次讲的时候呢我才会发现我可能哪个地方说的不是很清楚也有可能并不是我表达的不好可能还是我理解的还没还没更好一点所以所以通过这个分享这个过程我就感觉说就是嗯
可能能讓自己想得更清楚一些然後我印象比較深的就是說我就是在參加第一次那個那個TESHA龍的時候發現大家都在關注這個Leon的考考對就是TESHA龍第一節我就參加了那是內部的沒有對外然後發現大家什麼唐小巧哥啊然後還有這個張成威啊還有反正小青啊大家都在關注這個Leon的考考那是這種技術
后来我就学习了一下然后就运到共产里面然后运完以后呢我还专门把这个实践就写成了一个从redcog里面能学到什么那不用这个库还能学一支用吧应该是这样一个标题然后我就给团队分享哇第一次分享完以后我感觉我连自己我都不知道该怎么说想都想了半天然后然后就分享了很多次以后我才发现真的想清楚了所以我觉得这也是个很好的一个方法
我觉得分享其实有时候不一定要很多的能听可能两三个人就比如说我跟你也会再多加几个人这个过程其实也很有意思因为大家就会老会把不清楚的就问然后就像我不是每次分享会换一下图吗还能问我这个颜色是代表什么意思啊我就想居然会注意到这种细节其实我每次配图都会考虑颜色和代表意识只是就细节有点多啊就类似这样一些问题也会问就感觉很好
明白明白对我大概理解就大老师讲这个但我觉得其实说实话走弯路这个事情应该是我们大部分人都会面临的情况就真的很顺利然后就一直都是顺风顺水然后以往目前是少数的我是这么理解的所以我觉得像大老师的思路就是说我把这个走弯路的过程当作是我的一个是一种经验对吧
我走这些弯路其实恰恰会成我的经验然后另外后面的两个点因为我看直播间朋友在问他就是比如说他问试问说那个老师是怎么保持持续学习的我觉得戴老师这两个部分应该是很好的回答了这个问题就一个就是说肯定是要能去折腾吗不断的去折腾对于同一个问题要不断去升挖因为每一次升挖可能你都会获得不同的收获那第二个点就是说你在这个过程中要去做一些总结和分享
分享这个过程的话能帮助你去做一些总结然后你能得到一些别人的反馈能帮助你更好的去对你现有的知识体系做一个梳理和总结我是这么理解的对吧我们要理解对不对是对的没事好的好的那我们继续对因为应该讲的就是戴老师其实你肯定一直在在功课一些问题嘛在功课问题过程中你可以你肯定也会去做一些就是做一些知识的储备那你平时通过一些什么样的渠道去学习的呢
我觉得这个可能对于高校同学或者是对于一些比较初级同学应该会有比较有帮助对对就是我先前主要还是就是我可能学完了以后包括我包括我就是通过什么渠道我其实因为我比较喜欢分享以后呢我就会记录到博客或者什么里面然后到最近呢我就感觉就说可能想想是不是能够把他汇聚到一起所以我就用这个10月UI还要扛败
然后属于concurrency这个actors然后用它做了一个micro as 程序这个程序里面呢就说嗯会有一些资料然后这就是我平时可能会去看的就包括有些啊是练接然后也会有书的书单啊然后呃还会有些网站然后播客反正就是这个里面都会有
然后也提供了一些就是我会把一些就是我可能自己开发的时候会进因为开发的时候会去查一些这个语法就是这语法全背下来我觉得除了PVP的语法我是真的是全背下来但是SWIFT它没有因为它关键是太多了100多个吧PVP的材料多少它这个就是语法也太复杂了就是所以在这个手册就我做这个程序里面的手册里面其他它是可以很方便去查的我自己也会用这个去查
然后我还会就是包括用这个Foundation这个库这个Foundation库里面它实际上功能是不断的在迭代的我这话也会做一些更新嗯对然后另外呢就是呃我以前还写一篇文章这个文章我觉得它是就是一个开发的一个路线图嗯就是我这个标题就是LS开发语图就说我会把
就列得比较全,就像个大钢一样,然后我觉得这一块应该也可以看一看,还不错。然后另外还有一个点,还有一个很重要的点,刚刚想想,就是我觉得可以关注一些你觉得比较佩服的这样一些人,就是去看他的关注上,这个训练的方式特别好,然后你看他的动态,比如说我以前就在那个
就做后端那个时代我当时关注了一个叫Leave的就是V2EX的那个Leave的然后他我觉得真的还挺好以前他的经历他现在也在做那个麦克尔尔斯程序我觉得还挺好他以前是做这个论坛我也写过了嘛然后最近在看也在做这个考虑所以然后你可以看他提了一些知识啊或者这也挺好
OK好的 关于戴老师讲的两个点就是我们后续的话如果发总结的话我们会把那个直接发到我们的总结里面就一个是那个小册以及关于那个戴老师的那个就是那个图谱因为那个我也都看过OK然后有有同学说怎么去关注到戴老师啊这个其实大概可以去微博啊去微博搜索是戴名对不对是直接是你的名字吧直接微博搜索应该就能关注到你我觉得有个很简单很简单方法
就是不管是百度还是谷歌还是什么还是什么京东啊还是什么的都可以接受的这个情况就能看到哦对对对ok好的ok好然后呢那我们再进入下一个问题啊就这应该是大家在直播间也会很有意思就因为直播间间很多同学说很想跟戴老师学画画想跟戴老师学画ppt那其实我们也众所周知啊就戴老师是一个非常典型的鞋杠青年
所以很想了解一下就是你是怎么去成为一位鞋杠青年就是首先我觉得这个实际上是一个时间管理的一个问题就是说我觉得我还是就是有得还是有失的就是基本上我除了看这个中印节目和看一些乐波的这个电影电视剧以外那就就没干其他的比如说像那个唱歌跳舞啊反正就是其他的一些
那种活动或者反正很多可能大家都喜欢的一些东西我就都没有弄了也没有关注就完全就不看不看那些行不行然后所以我其他的事情上我想知道的乐趣也会少也会没有就不说少然后嗯另外一个就说我觉得有一个点比较重要就是可能在一段时间里面就是可能不是长期的就一段时间里面可以把输入减到一个极值
就不要什么都不看不听然后只做要承诺完成的事情就比如像今天这样一个分享我很早就承诺要做这样一件事情然后呢未来把这些事情做好的话我可能就比如说这几天我基本上什么都不看我最喜欢的终于能出一个歌我都没有听我只知道出这样然后嗯但是就是因为这是这是一个成功嘛所以他
的动力也比较强所以把速度减少然后最后全力以赴去做它这什么都不听怎么都不看然后结合的话呢就说因为最终可能大家知道我这个性权还是因为我把这个变成和换外结合前然后结合的这个第一次来说的话是也是内部的分享就当时这个智能布局碰到一个线上的问题就是IS6它老是工会因为那是智能布局刚出来的时候
然后二二二十六崩溃的话这个其实本身是系统的原因但是你需要解释因为滴滴这个用的很特别的多如果你解释不清楚那大家以后就不会用这个这种模式了所以我要让大家用我就真的我就要把这个技术的说清楚为什么不会崩虽然有办法可以解决但是我得说清楚所以就要进行调演我基本上把这个图书板都跑遍了清华的还有国家图书板所有跟这个相关的
我都放一遍只要是跟有尊重布局这一块我都看然后也没找到答案然后是后来正好那个WBC他有一个自动布局解密的那个session他就把这个原理讲一遍我就发现哦原来是在就是当时有一个那个循环的这样一个隐形这个图我也找了这个原因了然后找完了后呢其实我是很难解释的就说通过嘴巴很难解释就像我现在在描述一遍也很难所以我当时就
纸上画了一个图就炒打炒港那个炒个纸上画一个然后分享的时候呢我这个炒纸因为比较小黑色的纸因为下面好多冷的我不能直接给他们看然后我倒是还不会因为那个时候以前是没有分享过的就没有没有用过这些分享的团件所以我就直接在白边上一边画一边讲我发现这个效果就还不错然后大家会跟着我这个画的这个这个步骤啊然后他也能了解然后呢
就不停地问然后我正好也可以去接答所以我就感觉这个画画原来还能跟我做的事情变成能解决一下后来我再分享说我就多愿意用画画的方式去寻找然后但同时呢我还觉得画画有一个优点就是画画它也是一种形象的这个积极法就我以前大学就是考一个英语的时候然后被当时就是比较费时间然后我就一个当时画一张画
然后后来我去国外玩,然后就跟老外一起来,然后就看到一个交参,我就说,隐摸见识。然后老外说,哎,你说一个中国人,不是说一个中国人,就一个不说英语的国家类人,怎么居然还会知道隐摸见识的单词?我说,哎,怎么我一看见就想说这个呢?就是因为我这是形象记忆,所以我觉得这也是一个很好记东西的一个
我理解就是戴老师其实说白了就为了这个鞋杠听点还是做了一些牺牲的等于是因为人的经历是有限的嘛我理解可能戴老师就是说把技术和画画这个事情就是等于是把大部分的时间都分配给了这两个事情然后可能在中间的结合点的话其实是等于是还是找到了两眼之间的一些特性吧然后做了一些结合
另外另外我觉得其实有一个点是我觉得戴老师提到一个点其实能看出来一个点是呃戴老师是一个很专注的人这个肯定是无用质疑的因为你说可以要不要把别的东西说我都不去管确实挺难的有事情的时候才会专注不是有事情的时候才会专注其实是一般也不专注也是有的时候对对对就比如说有个事情在前面才会专注对而且我觉得另外有一个点就是戴老师应该是个很追求极致的人
因为我理解其实这每一页PBT应该都很难就你要把它画出来和相比说你在这个上面拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖拖
就像骑镜车就这种感觉吧就是你开始可能会每一步都要去想怎么做到后面就做多了就这么我好像就只用想这个炒稿就行的其他的就就炒稿你不用非准去画你其实脑袜里面够失这个过程差点就行真的下手去画很快了嗯可以的我觉得这个也是可以就尤其是大老师讲那个点
就画图可以是用形象记忆法嘛就群里的同学如果真对这个感兴趣的话也可以尝试一下就你后续比如说做一些就学习一些新的知识和技术的时候可以尝试着说用这种形象记忆法对 图像记忆法去做一些一些自己的这个记忆好的 那我们今天其实这个部分就是刚才提主要是片戴老师的个人部分嘛然后其实可能另外就是讲到因为我们是做大厂作严发嘛那其实就可能到另外一部分就是
关于大老师现在所在的团队快手嘛那我们其实想了解一下就快手团队它是一个审观的文化因为我们之前看到其实大老师应该还还代表的快手去做过很多这种跨界的一些访问就是采访嘛和一些分享对所以所以想通过大老师了解一下就是是快手的团队文化是什么样子就是说我去快手之前嘛就我到快手来之前我还在快手做过两次分享然后当时人都
就特別多我的感覺好像快手就是到場聽的人比其他的好像感覺還是要多一些特別是第一次第一次本身快手那也不斷那時候他在這個武大口那邊然後當時我們同事去了那邊然後讓我去分享然後我去完後他就說進那客戶站都在這然後我就我就覺得大家對這個技術的熱情真的是非常的高真的而且問的問題超多答不答不過來
第二次的时候我感觉有点把我就是问的应该就是问题好多都是出乎意料之外的然后所以我觉得他们首先快手的这个对技术的热情还是很高的就是我看到的另外这个快手扣端的团队啊也会有自己的这个公众号然后就是目前还是我在负责这个管理然后最近呢发了一个就是快手扣端的这样一个就是高效
放量的智能化实践这块是快手在智能化这块做的比较好的一个点就是说会在灰度放量这块就利用这种智能去提高转化率还要活跃度然后收益也非常的高我觉得这块就是创造率还是还是有的客户端的这块智能这块还是非常不错的然后另外就是说快手在启动上也做了一些用话
也做了一些輸出然後另外呢快手這邊有這個客戶專有這個開源的這個項目然後比如一個是這個當幕庫對就像這個Bilibili也有當幕Bilibili好像也開源過一個當幕庫我印象中好像是快手也有然後還有一個開源的庫這個是跟性能相關的就是有加庫
KORM的這樣一個線上內存監控的這樣一個庫然後這個庫做的也特別的好在這個目前是安久的這個版本就是然後是應該技術上有很大的突破當時安久同學也跟我講了我當時覺得他好像是在這個進程上做了一些這個處理然後跟其他的方案都不一樣就是有很多技術上的這個創新就創新的這個意思還是很強的然後總的來說吧就是快手這個
技术零是很技术的然后那个分享和看远对所以物以类聚吧就是这样子我明白这期也是戴老师为什么你会选择来快手这样的一个原因对吧味道相投好的那其实就涉及了一个问题因为其实像戴老师讲这样的因为我理解对于任何一个团队啊就是他的有一个非常好的技术文化氛围是非常重要的因为刚刚戴老师讲了这么多点那一定有
同学对快手这个团队是感兴趣的嘛那请想了解一下就你们目前有没有HCR然后包括你们招聘的话会比较看重这个候选人的什么素质呢这里这里可以看一下因为有高校同学在嘛可以分校招和社招都讲一下嗯可以就是首先这个我今天来之前也专门问了一下就是呃在这个校招这块有一个部落然后是呃上海跟北京
在这个就是主战这一块主战就是我们这个主APP这个技术品牌现在有这个销招的这个名额然后色招的话是海外我了解到应该有然后其他的的话就说我觉得有肯定是有然后大家就反正只管投就行了就是很简单投就可以然后我对销招这个看重就说不管是销招还是哎不对
要是校招和社招的看重点是不一样的我觉得校招比较看重的应该是学习的这样一个能力因为我以前也校招过在迪利的时候当时有三年吧我参加了三次这个校招就是去召学生然后我觉得学习能力高跟低其实非常的重要而且很容易看出这个区别
然后我当时也带过这个小招生我觉得只要是学习能力强的就是就比较好带一些然后他发展那边就是我现在因为这么多年了我就能看他现在发生什么样所以我觉得就比较看重的是学习能力然后然后另外呢就说嗯因为小招生他是没有雕塑过的但如果是社招生的话然后这个
他经历过很多的团队所以他的这个性格啊包括他这个气味像头就是这种他是他一定会有自己的一个气味在那所以说嗯社交可能出来基础了这些东西以外然后技术能力以外可能来看一下这个和当前这个团队是不是match然后这块呃因为快手也特别大那团队特别多所以也就是要应弄而已而已但是基础啊包括这个
这些知识啊这个我觉得还是还是还是很很重要这个也是要看然后嗯这话不好说一点呢也是因为就是我感觉吧招聘实样他是他其实是一种缘分就是我当时看这个孟怀露的时候就那个赵帕尔他当时就说他当时就有一个要解获的问题他就找了个和尚问他说
这个姻缘和烈缘就是应该怎么办如果本来我想要一段姻缘去碰上一段烈缘我应该怎么办然后那个和尚就跟刘一飞他就说说这个缘分啊关键在于自己怎么认为还不在于缘分本身所以我觉得能也是可以会变的所以你如果你真的追求的东西那个可能才是你真的想要你的
性格啊或者你的环境啊我觉得整说这种缘分关键在于你自身怎么去看的你如果觉得好那就是好的嗯明白好的好的那我觉得戴老师讲了很多包括其实他确实看了他最近应该有在追剧啊梦华录我也看过哈哈哈对OK嗯然后那其实关键是说现在是有HC的所以我觉得嗯在直播间同学就不管是高校的还是说
呃就是已经工作的可以通过我们直播间右下角的二维码加入我们的交流群啊然后进入交流群之后因为大老师就在群里嘛你们可以比如说有这种诉求的可以直接跟大老师联系把你的简历啊什么的发过去了解一下ok那啊刚才也讲了对吧因为我觉得这个问题刚才大老师应该讲过了就比如选择下家公司的时候会关注点是什么呃对吧跟刚才讲的就比如说一方面是说
呃 缘分对吧看一方面另外一方是味道对不对那除了这两个还有别的要补充的吗还有一个比较现实的一个原因嗯对就是原因的两个应该就是还比较虚了就我觉得现实的一个原因就是说还还会关注这个公司它的发展的方向嗯对因为我觉得这个方向其实本人就很难把控但是呃如果求稳或者说你觉得可能想
呆的就说更舒服一些可能这个公司他本身他这个方向是不是你认为你认同的可能很重要就对我来说也是一样就比如快手他现在目前他的就是视频和这个电商我觉得就是现在最好的一个方向所以我觉得这个方向也很重要明白所以这个这个方向因为我理解就是一个时代的
大的方向比如在这样的一个时代里面可能你觉得有时候你来快手你就觉得快手是在这样的一个时代里面它会相对比较有发展前景那其实能给到你更多的机遇嘛所以你觉得来了这样一个团队好的那就是确实我们刚才也讲过戴老师确实是经历很丰富那就就想了解一下就对于你这种有很多经历的人就这个过程中吧肯定也会存在一些困惑吧
人不可能说完完全全就很顺顺利利的不需要做任何思考也不会碰到任何困难就这么过来了很想了解一下就是你在碰到一些比较难的时候你是怎么去处理的对其实我觉得这个问题提的特别好就刚才说到的也是就是我觉得这个问题就是其实因为困过太多了你让我今天讲呢我可能只能讲一个因为我不可能所有的困回都讲所以我就想了一个就是说最困惑的一个事情就是从
很早到现在一直在困惑的一个问题包括我之中怎么处理的就是说当然第一个比较我可以也可以先说一下我第一个比较方向型的困惑呢就说做我是做开发呢还是做画画呢是吧这是我第一个比较困惑的啊但是现在也没有处理所以我就只是提一下然后第二个呢就是嗯就我就说一下画画中有些困惑就是画画首先会
比较担心自己的身体因为我画起来就停不下来尽量什么都不会顾如果家里要没有人的话我经常一整天都不是饭从头画到尾然后而且每次准备PPT就都会起得特别早我也不知道为什么就会有时候会睡得很早但是起已经是起得早然后3点4点就起来然后就不断的画了上班的时间就这样然后有时候看一幅画也会看半天
不是看我的自己的话就是看别人的就是看一些展的就是发呆就是一看完就不停的想想很多所以这样其实对身体特别的不好然后这也是一个点然后以前呢就是画画的这个过程中呢我一直关比较关注这个线条还光影然后嗯最近呢就是才会去想怎么画才会好看因为以前那些都是可能是些知识但是
可能不是结果结果是要画好看嘛所以我可能后面才会想这些然后然后以前怎么感觉的就说我觉得是不是画画得不好看是不是因为基础不好比如说是不是线条不好因为那时候我什么都不行那时候我就觉得好看的线条就是好看的话所以我就练线条然后练其实我说这个时间大家可能以为就那么一画
像前年后后,我从小就开始喜欢的到现在30,30,40年嘛就是周期是很长的,然后就念线条然后线条觉得差不多了发现不好看不一定线条好就好看有时候看小孩子画的话都比我画线条画的就是那并不是核心点所以很困惑然后呢后来就想那是不是颜色的问题因为小孩子不颜色图很漂亮然后就念配色去试然后
不行那后来又倒订图书是不是好的光影啊是不是结构啊形体啊因为不是都先学这些东西嘛谁说我一直要走弯呢就是确实是这样但是我也没有想着就是非得要先得到一个答案我觉得走弯的其实真的可以可以难得体验更多的东西嘛就是所以后来也不行然后光影这个完了以后就是就是
因为这些当我掌握了一些原理知识以后然后引练了一些以后然后就发现也不行可能还有的是就是把这几个都做到为了画一不好看然后我就想那是不是有有一句话很有名就是画画里面的我和关注很多画画的他就说画画其实就是画个对比度我说那是不是要把对比度调好一点调高一点是吧然后发现这个也不行实际上就是我也会看很多的话
所以這些規律都很難很難體會出來所以有時候我會發很多呆就是去因為有困惑才會發呆那有時候晚上教育睡不好特別難受然後我覺得這個時候我就覺得難得是我心上水平提到了所以才總會覺得畫得不好看後來其實不是就不好看就真的是不好看因為一個小孩他也能看出一個畫得不好看然後所以我一直都都沒有得到解答
所以我每次看画的时候我觉得老爱想就是这个画这幅画的或者这个设计师或者这个画的画家或者这个设计师他是在怎么考虑着他的这个想法是什么样子画成这样一幅画的然后我就从我喜欢的画画里面我最喜欢的有一个人叫那个住卡然后他画的画呢就是就怎么看都很好看然后我就买了一本他的书然后呢
翻著看我一天一就是可能一週吧會看一夜到兩夜然後這個書我現在還沒看到上一然後我正好就看到有一段裡面他說什麼是美他寫了一個問句我說完了我是不是馬上就要知道答案了所以我看這個問題以後我趕緊就跑掉了然後不敢看這個答案但是後來就是也很好奇就還是最終還是看了
他说了说完了这个答案我看完以后恍然大悟竟然我这么几十年的这个这个这个这个一共回遭然后他是这么说的他说美啊就是美学啊就是美这个东西他其实就是在混乱中的一个有序就是美然后我结婚以前所有碰到的那些觉得不好然后我在结婚他就我好像就毛色动态的这么感觉真的
太棒了这个观点然后也可以理解我就解了我这个困惑然后所以我一旦看到这个完了以后我再看一些影视作品比如说有个影视作品叫大圣诞波罗大圣诞波罗这个片子他就是他虽然很老啊这个片子但他无论从构图配色还有光影等等各个方面他每一帧都是就是非常的完美还有服装太完美了这个片子然后我现在就能看更多东西我就是他为什么没
然后我也能发现和理解更多的美我觉得这点是非常奇妙如果我不走那么多弯的直接给我这个答案我感觉我体会不到或者说还得过这么多年我才能可能把这个口诀给解啊就是这种感觉明白对 我觉得我觉得戴老师分享了一个很有意思的故事啊就因为我平时也画画嘛对戴老师我们其实最早认识的时候就是因为我们都画画然后认识的
然後我待會講這些東西我作為畫畫的角度我是可以理解的但我不知道我覺得直播間同學可能不能理解待會講這個故事但我是感受挺深的但我覺得其實總結一下兩個點我自己的感覺就跟畫畫沒有關係我覺得第一個是大老師他的心態是非常非常好的這個點我覺得他就是他面對一些曲折或者說一些這些弯路的時候他的心態是很健康的他會去立想去思考一些事情
然后第二点就是他在碰到困难的时候他其实呃你们发现没有就他会尝试去去找一些有经验的人去看看别人怎么做对吧我觉得这两个点其实是我在戴老师整个讲的过程中我觉得是我自己会有一些感受就可能对于直播间大家也会有帮助的两个点不知道我理解对不对的是是对太太太对了嗯我觉得大家
对我觉得大家可以学习一下因为就是一个一个是心态因为很多问题面对一些问题的时候其实心态是更重要的因为问题有大有小而且每个时候只能自己去体会但是你这种比较好的心态会帮助你去至少你能更冷静的去思考这个问题嘛对吧然后然后前人的一些经验其实也会对你有一些帮助包括我们其实忍不住要讲我们这个活动啊就我们会讲我们为什么会做我在大厦做研发这个活动其实也是希望说一些
真的比较自身的一些专家们的一些经验能给到大家一些呃就是这些想法能给到大家一些帮助ok非常非常感谢大老师啊这个这个分享ok然后我觉得今天的最后一个问题吧就是想了解一下就是大老师你觉得你现在这个团队以及个人就是将来会有一些什么的规划呢就是嗯从这个嗯
我从两个点就是现在关注的这个领域现在关注什么领域然后还有这个职业生涯这一块来说一下然后关注领域的话就是还是我就是提到的这个V2VS这个Leavitt他他关注的一些点他现在也就说我发现了有一个领域就说他做了一个叫Planet就是这个怎么翻译地球嘛对吧
星球就他做了这样一个软件然后这个软件的作用是什么呢就他说他这个这个软件是可以直接在自己的这个电脑上去发布一个网站或者就是把自己这个博客呢就发了这个ipfs这个上面然后这个网站呢或这个博客他是可以绑定一个英S这样一个域名就点一Ti去这样一个结尾的一个域名嗯他实际上这个过程就是把这个contact hash然后
就是和這個英文S這個合約上進行這樣一個操作就當然他他做了一個點比其他的好他就是說你只用綁一次就可以他第一次會有這個幹事的這個費然後後面就不會有然後呢ipfs和英文S他都是去中心化的就是你可以解釋就是我們經常的這種點了點就是我我電腦中心就是我發我在我電腦上發佈我並不用傳到這個服務器上你就能直接來看嗯然後
大概这样一个结束因为它是以前它就一直是做这个浮戏端的所以我感觉好像就它实际上是看到的未来未来实际上是扣端的就没有浮端什么事啊就有就肯定都是扣端的所以选择做扣端这个方向的一定是不会有问题的以后肯定是会把这个浮端给去除掉的因为就不会发生荡机这种就是
变态的盛行然后也会比较回到互联网最开始的自由的状态然后他这个App去说话他也做了很多自己的一些功能就是说在这个App上面就是说我可以去Follow一个人然后他的在字上面的更新你就能看到就类似于iS是订阅这样一种形式然后我在上面发东西然后订阅我的也能自己看到
它就不依賴一个中心化的这样一个音频我觉得这首先它是一个方向这个APP只是它的就它刚发布然后后面肯定还是会完善但是就这个方向我觉得还是挺好就是这个领域不错然后另外我还在关注的就是这个编译啊ID1和这个文本编辑器相关的一些技术我刚才也提到了这个工程这样一个体校啊它实际上很多很多现在的这种
工程提效的它都利害于一个中台这个中台来说的话实际上就是把我们分析啊或新上类数据都都直接在这个网页上去去操作展示但是我实际上觉得这有点隔离就是因为我们一般都是用编辑带写我们的就是做技术人肯定是喜欢用一种技术的方式去去看东西的所以你分析出来的结果就能体验到自己本身的编辑上这种形式我觉得是更容易接受的所以想在这上面就是去发下力
就是文本的編譯去ide還編譯這個技術這幾個領域我覺得也是比較關注也是像這個團隊也是一樣的就這一塊做多一點讓大家體驗更好一些那另外比較失能一點的吧就是我個人其實也很喜歡玩遊戲就現在玩的雖然很少但是以前那肯定是沒得命的玩的所以現在就是從技術上的
比较喜欢看这个摩利器啊这种因为摩利器就刚才提到这个虚机这个技术所以就是这摩利器能够把以前那么老的一些游戏都拿到现在的嘛这么多式的然后GbGb的然后Gb也用还SWIFT写了一个Gb这个摩利器然后叫叫叫叫什么来着SWIFT的play那个Pokemon就是玩那个寶可梦Gb上的寶可梦不是最有名的然后另外还有个SWIFT就比较有名的一个摩利器项目叫OpenEMU
就是也算是為了開發的他開發的是就能夠玩這個GBA呀還有這個PSPPS的遊戲就多了玩這些遊戲都是我以前就是特別投入的玩去玩的一些遊戲嗯那比如說像什麼金融群下鑽就多時的這種叫有一個當這個就不是實惠寫他是他是用這個世界家寫的一樣是用世界家寫叫多時boxpure這樣一個
就是有一个开源项目这几个都是开源项目所以对这个项目我也很有兴趣就一方面可以想了解一下这个莫丽琪啊训绩啊他们的一些一些怎么就怎么做的就是比较开兴趣就这一块啊另外对于就这个紫牙这块就打算了接下来当真职职业上来说的话呢就是还是苹果因为上面我提到了这些东西苹果这肯定一个是
都不会放过的首先也是比较重这个口段的然后游戏他也我看他现在这个动作应该也比较会在这上面发力然后包括包括那个VR这种虚拟现实是正常现实虚拟现实这种游戏他都会去做然后苹果本身他也有自己的这个ID啊编印章一些技术自己的语言然后我觉得这个就是还是会玩到苹果这个当然苹果如果是
不行了那一定是有比蘋果更好的所以只要能比蘋果好那我覺得也能接受所以就是大概就是這樣直接剩下就是目前還是以這個蘋果為主因為我很喜歡蘋果產品因為我覺得蘋果產品就有一種雖然他也是學了這個德國的一個設計師吧然後做出來的所有的這些風格但是我覺得他的心臟水平比較高
这也是很了解的,他知道学,他能学个好的,他终于学一个不好的好。我其实理解下来,刚才提戴老师讲的武帝其实也相当于相似两个方向吧。第一个其实,但我觉得戴老师这两个回答其实是给克伯丹同学打了一针强心计啊。
刚才看到我也在看关注直播间我发现很多同学都说什么iOS啊没有前途了客户当然没有前途了对吧这个所以我觉得戴老师刚讲这个点其实蛮重要的我看直播间有同学没听到我就再解释一下吧其实刚才讲的戴老师讲那个为什么不需要服务器是因为是去中心化就我们现在其实整个web2.0的时代都是中心化的部署嘛对吧所有的数据啊什么的都是有一个服务器的东西的但去中心化之后呢其实所有东西都在
我们都是节点所以其实我觉得大老师讲那个东西是广义的客户端懂吧就是大家不要理解为是我们现在的单纯的写APP这样的一个状态就是我们写APP有很多种吗就不是说写UI之类的东西它说是个广义的客户端的东西那未来的技术肯定是不一样的但客户端肯定是按照大老师这个讲法客户端是有前景的它是个广义的客户端的概念然后第二个点其实我觉得
大老师还是说在往深度上去走呢不管是讲的这些模拟器啊然后刚才讲的那些ide的东西它其实都是相对于说就往更底层就往边一层或者是往系统层去走的呃我不要这个理解是不是对的大老师对对你没说行的好的那我觉得就相当于大老师这两一点思路的话也相当于是给直播间的同学能够提供一些思路吧大家不要真的觉得客户端不行客户端还是行的
好吧 真正有危机的应该是服务上的那些同学